we live in a constant tangle of charging
cables whether we're at home on-the-go
in our office it seems as if our
wireless devices are constantly attached
to wires now the king of home
organization IKEA thinks they have a
solution this is like Kia's new line of
wireless charging furniture the line
consists of lamps tables and charging
pads and the price ranges anywhere from
10 to $119 how does it work
it uses key which is a wireless charging
standard that is supported by most of
the major players with the notable
exception of Apple if you want to use an
Apple device you have to buy an adaptive
case all of them however are really
really ugly so to use it just take a key
enable phone and drop it onto the
charging pad and it'll start to charge
doesn't always work though you have to
be very precise about where you place
the phone so the coil is perfectly line
up with the charger another downside is
that it doesn't charge as quickly as it
would if you had just plugged the phone
in I've been playing with this device
for a week now and using the cord is
always a bit faster part of why it
doesn't charge as quickly is because it
will stop charging as soon as you pick
up the phone also when it's on the
charger it generates quite a bit of heat
akia said it will automatically shut off
on the phone gets too hot but let's face
it
heat is never good for a phone the
funniest part about this is that IKEA
recognizes the shortcomings of this
technology and they've added a USB port
on every piece of their furniture so you
can plug your phone in the normal way
anyways at the end of the day it's not
that much different from having your
phone plugged into a cord you still have
to leave it in one place for it to get
power
we don't need wireless charging we need
better batteries
you